[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "BELIEVER"]
You made me a--
DAN REYNOLDS: I feel
like for many years--
[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "BELIEVER"]
--believer.
--it was, I don't
really know who we are.
[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "BELIEVER"]
You made me a--
But this tour is the
first time that I knew
we are, Imagine Dragons.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, here we are.
DAN REYNOLDS: Our goal was
to be a self-sustained indie
band that could make
enough money to pay
rent and have food.
No idea that it
would be this big.
That's one in a billion.
DANIEL WAYNE SERMON: We're
all past our wildest dreams.
There's no words
for a night like this.
We will give you
everything, because you
have given us everything.
[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "BELIEVER"]
You made me a, you
made me a believer, believer.
DANIEL WAYNE SERMON: If we
were playing for five people,
Dan was still larger
than life on stage.
He's always been that guy.
[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "BELIEVER"]
Come on.
You made me a, you made me a--
CROWD: --believer.
Still feels like we're
the hungry band
playing five nights a week.
DAN REYNOLDS: Every day
that we have is a gift.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
May we spend less
time being divided,
may we spend more time
loving, more time forgiving.
I get a look at people's faces.
I get to see them feel
happy, cry, and sing the song
at the top their lungs.
[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "MY LIFE"]
These years pass
by, and we're growing older.
And I think of you,
always made it through.
I have lost too many
people who think
that their life doesn't matter.
Your life always matters.
[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "MY LIFE"]
These years
pass by, and I'm growing older.
Imagine Dragons just really
wants to make people feel safe
and loved.
[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "MY LIFE"]
So you've passed away.
There's no words to sing.
No second trust.
Is this love?
DANIEL WAYNE SERMON:
It's a bigger stage,
but nothing's really changed.
[IMAGINE DRAGONS, "MY LIFE"] Is
this really my life, my life?